la ceinture monsieur ah oui à 90 retards
à la main dans le sac monsieur ça fait
100 francs vous me réglez maintenant
parce que je vais fermer la casse la wii
d'âge encaisse là je suis en quête
centre en flagrant délit ah bah si vous
avez passé un coup de pêcheurs tout un
homme après celle 350 ha oui c'est bien
parce que nous en même temps c'est moins
cher que d'habitude et ça nous permet
d'arrondir les fins de mois à la noyade
vous avez un discours que vous ne
devriez pas voir pourquoi monsieur je
vous dis ça vous avez un discours que
vous ne pouvez pas voir pourquoi ça nous
permet nous de picoler à la brigadière
c'est faux bien que bon ça ira les
médias tension chéri le camion arrivait
vous m'avez dit attention chercher 10 à
madame parce qu'elle était sur la rue on
fera autant c'est vous qui avait
klaxonné bien sûr du tout je vous ai vu
monsieur ça ma main au feu je vous ai vu
monsieur mai à valence est et la
ceinture comme la ceinture
il faut l'enlever la ceinture monsieur
vous ne lisez pas les journaux il ya qu
une ceinture depuis hier monsieur non
c'est pas du tout un gars que vous
retirez la ceinture monsieur c'est trop
dangereux on a eu trop de morts ça les
gens restent coincés à les retirer la
ceinture et filet non mais vous dessus
on l'a persuadé monsieur attention on
est là pour ça prévention information
arqués trottoir 8
on marche on le croira pas sur la route
le tueur c'est très gênant à batna pas
contrôler la suspension je vous
demandais descend du véhicule s'il vous
plaît y en a trois secondes vous asseyez
on va faire les deux côtés les six
mentions être poubelles qui roule sur le
capot van hamme ont fait le côté droit
voilà sauter un petit peu retiré les
chaussures vous monter dessus et après
c'est bon allez y retirer mes chaussures
vous monter dessus et vous vous sentiez
bon cela ils vont fait l'autre
maintenant si allusion le fais tout le
temps allez-y de beau sauter sur un pied
sur un pied allez-y sur un pied c'est un
ordre l'été la capuche monsieur métais
la capuche c'est obligatoire maintenant
et la loi monsieur s'est passé ce matin
au journal officiel
si vous avez un accident capuche
maintenant où tombe de monsieur la
capuche amorti le choc
on est d'accord mais bon j'en clairement
pas à ben je verbalise monsieur ya pas d
autorisation possible pour
pour les blaireaux pardon montrer plus
non mais parce qu'elle m'avait dit de
voir au commissariat de police que pour
une durée de quelques semaines
concernant je rangerai avec un billet
tout peut s'arranger avec la police
enfin quand je dis petit c'est une façon
de parler ça fait 800 francs même nom à
six sont des amendes à 800 francs 1 800
ha bah oui parce que les gens vous
rendre notre pare chocs et je suis pas
responsable des gens qui vont rentrer
dedans madame à savoir les colmariens
vont casser maintenant parce que la
faveur que j'ai un nom marqué ce nobel
non il faudrait si un petit procès
verbal et condition c'est que vous
voudriez un petit quelque chose d'autres
voulaient traverser monsieur non parce
qu'il faut que je fasse ce verset 20
foire des personnes par jour je les
quotas de 1 voulais me à bon compte
voulait way boitard résigne à les
analyser les bonjour monsieur on nous a
signalé une échelle voler dans paris rue
du dragon monsieur
richter a porté plainte vous avez une
échelle je pose la question de confiance
s l'échelle de richter monsieur vous
jouez sur l'honneur le jusque là où tu
as d'accord vous allez vous monsieur
l'année dans le parc et vous allez vous
après
ça que j'ai rendez vous devant le statut
de césar auquel vous allez me déposer
parce que la cherchons un coup de filet
chez ma fille kate à la crèche ma femme
devait passer la prendre un sacré talent
village ont fait l'aller retour
ok merci c'est très gentil
jeudi matin on va juste à créteil
monsieur il ya 40 km enfin je peux pas
du tout mais c'est police monsieur mais
c'est un ordre
mais c'est un homme ne peut pas et ma
fille moi je ne peux pas demander un
suivant un taxi je peux voir donnez moi
la cour du tas qui donne au moins 50
francs votre femme n'a pas deux ans et
demi elle va pas pleurer avec son goûter
à la mort ma fille oui non mais ma fille
ma fille est enceinte s'appelait la
surveillait monsieur mais rouler sur le
pied madame vous m'avez roulé sur le
pied madame un agent de la force
publique
bon maintenant où emmener chez moi je
peux plus requis et moi
creteil village c'est la marche
voilà j'ai eu huit jours d'arrêt de
travail je vais dîner chez vous ce soir
ça vous embête pas qu'est ce qu'il ya à
manger une dinde
ah bah ça ne changera de la miel
sanctions économiques merci et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais 1 pouces bleus